there are only three sharks that
regularly attack humans the massive
great white the Swift sleek tiger
and the often ignored but dangerous bull
shark
my kite house from Florida International
University studies the bull probably get
the name bull shutters they're so big
and stocky I kind of think of it more as
the pit bowl of the scenes it's a
fitting description bull sharks can be
tenacious and aggressive they're not as
large as the great white but female
bulls can grow to over 11 feet and weigh
up to 500 pounds they also have one very
special characteristic one of the most
amazing things about these bull sharks
is that they go from marine to
freshwater with no problems Bulls have
been found thousands of miles upstream
in both the Mississippi and Amazon
rivers they also are believed to hunt in
the same shallow coastal waters where
unsuspecting beachgoers frolic in the
summer
there are also opportunistic hunters
they'll eat just about anything Mike
wants to know more about bull sharks and
their feeding habits so he's attached
critter cams to the Sharks
underwater cameras equipped with
satellite tags once ready there's our
shot nice boys
that's exactly what we need
the Crittercam reveals at least one
other bull in the region which raises
the intriguing possibility that these
sharks may be interacting satellite data
also confirmed that the Bulls stay put
never venturing far from where the team
caught them that's more proof that these
animals may be an important part of the
coastal environment but in regards to
sharks and us it showed that Bulls do
like to hunt and hang out in the same
shallow waters we flock to every summer
ultimately though it does us all good to
remember that you are more likely to get
struck by lightning than bit by a shark
you